- How much would I pay
today to sit in the room
when Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates had their first meeting?
And I was like oh, that
would be super weird.
I'd pay a lot.
The number one thing
I always say to myself
when I think about that,
what would I pay the most money for,
is to be in the room the day
somebody decided to sell-
(slow electronic music)
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(slow R&B music)
- Hello, world.
My name is Tyler Schmitt.
We are here in L.A. at the new office.
Full day, bounced around L.A.
Gary did some client stuff
this morning, 8:00 a.m.
Coming into the office, little 4Ds.
- Because hiring is guessing.
Firing is knowing.
- And then tonight, USC
talk, which will be cool.
(audience cheering)
- Hey!
- Live fucking life, bro!
- Yes! I love you so much.
- I love you back! (kisses)
- Yes!
(yells excitedly)
- 36 hours in L.A.,
Gary will be here soon.
Whirlwind will be created,
meetings will be canceled,
meetings will be moved.
(laughing in background)
And we will keep rockin' and
rollin' one day at a time.
(side chatter)
Here we go.
(fast guitar music)
- 'Sup, Tyler?
Ready?
I bought a 173 Giannis
rookie cards in August
for a buck fifty.
Now they're $380.
And the market's liquid as fuck.
I believe the culture's gonna go into it.
But Jordan rookies I
bought for $3200 in August,
they're trading at $6000.
You know, you go out and buy fucking-
- What is the marketplace
you're looking at?
- Ebay.
- It's liquid as fuck.
Tyler bought some fucking
sticker of some soccer kid,
he scores a hat trick,
what happened in one day?
- I always get about 18 or 35 in a week.
- [Gary] And I'm about
to personally push it,
like I'm about to, I'm gonna turn cards-
- That's the way to move.
- Dude, was that amazing?
Was that so good?
(commentators reporting softly)
- [Man] I always liked this story
that you said that you wore
that at your first WrestleMania
or when you went-
- How about this, show him!
(laughing)
- You saw it?
- [Man] Oh yeah, it's crazy.
- How about this?
Somebody found it.
- Okay.
I haven't seen it yet 'cause
I didn't have the software.
- This was before and after?
- [Gary] I haven't seen it yet.
- I like that.
- I went to WrestleMania for-
- Oh he made one, huh?
(video playing)
- Yeah, when Tyson, the
best part of that one,
- I come down with a sign
that says "I love the Jets".
- Oh, the sign.
(crowd cheering)
(laughing)
- That's amazing!
Holy shit, I can't believe I did that.
I'm fucking crazy,
literally, it makes no sense.
I have a need to hack WrestleManias
and push Jets propaganda.
That's basically my 20 year plan.
Every 20 years, I hack
WrestleMania with Jets propaganda.
- [Man] You should create a Jets character
to go into the WWE.
- I want to be.
I'm probably gonna be in WrestleMania.
- [Gary] I swear to God,
I would pay right now,
this is why I started
filming, I would pay five-
So I believe one day, somebody
will actually be sitting
in this seat and paying my
great-great-grandchildren
$9.00 for the right to do it.
I believe that VR will get so advanced,
- Got it.
- That the library of my
content will allow for people
to actually feel like they're sitting
in this room right now in 57 years.
- Sure.
- So when I thought about that,
that's a hypothesis of mine.
I know it's a little weird,
but I kind of weirdly believe it.
So then I started thinking, if
I believe in that hypothesis,
how much would I pay
today to sit in the room
when Steve Jobs and Bill
Gates had their first meeting?
And I was like oh, that
would be super weird.
I'd pay a lot.
The number one thing
I always say to myself
when I think about that,
what would I pay the most money for,
is to be in the room the day
somebody decided to sell bottled water.
(laughs)
- I don't know why, but
I'm so fascinated by it.
It comes out of the sink for free,
and somebody literally just goes,
"We're gonna sell it."
And I have to assume, the
only comp I have right now
is if I look you dead in the face
and said, "I'm really gonna sell oxygen."
Straight up.
(light hip hop music)
I'm heading to Rich Eisen's show,
Rich Eisen, iconic sports commentator,
NFL network, former ESPN,
and talk NFL draft, I guess.
Jet's season, I don't know.
Definitely gonna be lit
'cause I get excited on there.
I'm gonna lose my mind.
- But that has not-
- Dude, you cannot use MVP as
a variable to a sports debate,
it is a ludicrous data point!
- It is not!
- Okay.
- [Man] You were talking
about sports cards heavily
to the upcoming guys.
Why do you think that you're
able to see those trends come?
- I don't know.
I don't know why certain
things become obvious to me,
social media, the internet itself,
rappers, you know.
First of all, I don't predict anything.
So, there's an article on
Forbes.com right now that says,
"Sports cards up another 15%
as an alternative investment".
What I'm good at is actually knowing
something's gonna extend.
- [Man] Extend?
- Extend, I think people
see things that I see.
I think certain people,
I think I'm very good
at understanding if something's
gonna be a fad for a month
or a trend for three years.
- [Man] Mmm.
- That's what I'm good at.
- [Man] Mhmm.
- Right?
- [Man] Do you think
it's with things mainly
that you're also already passionate about?
- Potentially.
- [Man] And other things
that you maybe don't see
or you don't-
- Potentially, potentially.
Yeah, well let's start with this.
I have to see it.
I'm not passionate about slime,
but I was right about, that
kids were gonna play with slime
for awhile 'cause I saw it playing out.
I'm not passionate about
skateboarding culture,
but I knew that when Lil
Wayne started doing stuff
that urban kids would be wearing Vans.
So I need to see it.
- [Man] Mhmm.
- So if you take me to a heavy metal,
if you bring me into your world,
if I play for a week, I'll know.
- [Man] Mmm.
- I could literally know
nothing, like I do right now,
about hardcover heavy
metal right this minute,
and if you gave me a week to be in a c-
if I went on tour with the top ten player,
studied for a week, did what I did,
in a week, I would have
a hot take, an insight,
a hypothesis that would be good.
- [Man] Hmm, I feel like
we should play this out.
You wanna go mosh?
- I mean...
(beep)
(heavy metal music)
- I don't wanna hurt anybody out there.
(laughs)
You know what I'm sayin'?
Ah, you know, if I had more time,
like one day when I truly have time,
that would be a great show,
where every week I go
into some crazy new world
and I come out with my hot take.
That'd be such a great show.
I spend a week, right?
In like farming and be
like, "My hot take is..."
That'd be really cool, actually,
that's an amazing show.
How are you?
- [Man] Doing good.
- Good.
- [Man] Gary?
- Yes.
- [Man] Holy shit, how you doin'?
- I'm well, thank you, sir.
- I love your stuff, it's awesome.
- Thank you, bro, I appreciate that.
- See it on LinkedIn all the time.
- Thank you, thanks for watching.
Hello, sir.
- How are you?
- It's good to see you.
- He just told me the story
of finding your wallet.
- Oh, you found it.
- Caleb.
- Holy shit.
- Do you know about this?
Caleb found Rich's wallet at the combine.
Caleb finds a wallet, opens it.
- It was after I left your event.
- Caleb, holy shit.
- I know, thank you.
Come on in.
- Wait, did you give him the-
- No, we kept the wallet,
we kept the wallet.
We still have the wallet.
Thank you, sir.
- You're welcome.
- [Rich] Watch your step.
Do you want any makeup
or anything like that?
We can make you look nice.
- Nah, I don't need it.
- Come on in.
- Okay cool, what's up everyone?
Hey, how are you guys, good to see you.
It's great to see you again.
- How's everything?
- Really well, good to see you.
What's up, brother, you ready?
You ready for this season?
- Yes.
Always, man, you kidding me.
- Hey, what's happening, man?
- It's a pleasure.
How's the family?
- Great, how about you?
- Everything's really good.
Oh, my brother had a baby today!
- No, shit.
- Yeah, AJ had a baby.
- Happy uncle day.
- Hello, how are you guys, hello everyone.
- Hoping that the schedule
will be released today,
so we have the Jets' schedule.
- [Gary] And is it supposed
to come today or tomorrow?
- It's supposed to tomorrow
at eight o'clock at night.
- But I already know a
lot about the schedule.
- Okay, great.
- So we can talk about it.
- So if you want.
- Reed, you know the first
game of the season is Jets.
- Cleveland.
- Browns, Monday night.
- Suppose he was leaked, but
is it fake news or is it real?
- It was definitely
firm a little while ago,
and then they un-firmed it,
but I still think it's gonna be-
It's the 50th anniversary
of Monday Night Football!
- [Rich] It's the 100th season of the NFL
and it's all about history.
It's the first ever
Monday Night Football...
(voices overlapping)
- ...Watching Odell, I
mean, we'll discuss it.
Come on out, we'll do this.
(footsteps)
- Here we go.
- Bobby Beathard is in the Hall of Fame?
- [Man] This year.
- But he made it or he's a finalist?
- Three, two...
- Thrilled to have here on the program,
I could spend the entire time that I have
with this man by introducing him,
but he's the chairman of VaynerX,
the active CEO of VaynerMedia.
You follow him on Instagram
and Twitter @GaryVee.
- Oh god, I could do this all day.
I might, I might have to retire.
(slow hip hop music)
- Hey.
- How are you, good to see you.
- Good to see you, brother.
- [Gary Voiceover] My career
has a really funny moment in it
which is when I went
double-down on Vayner.
September 2011 to 2013, 2014,
I was pretty quiet for me on the internet.
It was very little.
There's only like the keynotes,
there's like a couple things.
I was very quiet.
And then when I came back,
I was more self-aware.
And what did I start?
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Sometimes when I talk to
Caleb or anybody at my team,
I'm the breakout personality
in the business space
in this last couple years,
while actively being a CEO,
and CEO of a massive company.
And when I talk to them,
could you imagine if I was just Gary Vee?
Every morning, I would
do a fucking morning show
from 8:00 a.m. to 11:00 a.m., just Q&A.
You think I'm penetrating
all the channels now?
It'd be over.
I would do it everyday.
It's my favorite thing to do.
Tea with Gary Vee!
You know, a nice glass of tea.
Just put 'em on, call me.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
clip, clip, clip,
distribute, distribute.
Everyday!
Look how pumped we get when we do-
One of the reasons I did
4Ds was for the fuckin',
what did I just say?
Because hiring is guessing.
Firing is knowing.
That fucking thing is
gonna kill on LinkedIn.
That's two million in the bank.
(laughing)
But I need to be asked.
It's hard to self-start.
It's not, I apologize, I'm
really great at self-starting,
that's why it was good.
It's just, I'm only
gonna say the same things
that I believe in.
The only time I do new
shit is when I'm asked.
That's why I started,
and if you know that about yourself,
make it a Q&A show, right?
- Yeah, just show much fun.
- So fun, especially
when you stay in your-
The biggest thing I'll tell
you is just stay in your lane.
I think a lot of people,
when they start Q&A,
have a sense of like, "I'm an expert
and I should have an answer for this."
It happened yesterday,
I don't know, right?
I have no ego, I've lived my own truth.
If I never write another
headline for myself,
then I wasn't good enough.
I don't know, nonetheless,
I'm super pumped to
tell them I don't know.
(slow hip hop music)
(audience cheering)
- The relationship between
success and failure,
how do you define success,
and how is it related to failure?
- I define success as
waking up and being happy
and being able to do what
you want to do at all times.
(audience applause)
- ...it's apparent we have
everything to be successful now.
- It's super simple,
and we are absolutely
at an inflection point
where there is people like me
and different things happening
where we're starting to have
different conversations.
Freedom is what everybody's chasing,
but they're confused about
what it actually looks like.
It's not how much you make,
it's how much you spend.
There's a lot of people
that could be way more free
if they didn't overextend
themselves on what they're buying.
(slow hip hop music)